TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Leading up to the launch
of their time management
game, Cooking Craze,
Big Fish Games
ran an open beta on Google Play.
And they found that
using open beta
provided more than 10x the
amount of user feedback
from around the
world and also gave
them access to key metrics
and Android Vitals,
in the Play Console.
For more details,
check out the video
on the post linked in
the description below.
Our 14th and 15th Google
Cloud Platform regions
have opened in the
Netherlands and Canada.
For more details and to get
started with Google Cloud
Platform in those regions
today, head on over to the post.
If you've got a monolithic
.NET application that
you're re-architecting
using Microservices,
this white paper
series is for you.
The latest installment is
entitled Modernizing Your .NET
Application for Google Cloud,
and it's available from
the post.
Custom Roles for Cloud
Identity and Access Management
give you the ability to pick
the precise permissions people
need to do their jobs, and they
are now generally available.
More details are on the post.
The Google Cloud
Security Team developed
a scanner that can help make
sure all your Google Kubernetes
Engine clusters are
running a Virgin patched
against the Meltdown and
Spectre CPU vulnerabilities.
It's available now from
within Forseti Security,
an open source security toolkit
for Google Cloud Platform.
Details and links
are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
Thanks for watching yet another
week of The Developer Show.
If you missed some
prior weeks, maybe
click on them right over here.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]